Thought your children were safe from SPERM?
Think again!
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - with a heartwarming
tale about sperm, and all the ways it can
screw up your future children.
You may remember a Dnews I did a while back
that talked about memories - and specifically,
phobias - being passed down through our DNA.
And if you thought that was terrifying - it
gets worse.
A study published in this week's issue of
Nature Neuroscience finds that past trauma
can also be passed down to your children - through
sperm.
It's long been known that children and grandchildren
of people who've survived traumatic events
- like abuse or war - are more likely to experience
mental illness than the rest of the population.
But despite hundreds of studies, there are
still no known genes responsible for depression
and borderline personality disorder.
According to this study, people who experience
early childhood trauma often exhibit a number
of hormonal imbalances, including over-expression
of microRNAs, which are snippets of genetic
material that regulate gene expression.
Too many of these, can cause a dip in the
production of certain proteins.
Researchers exposed a group of male mice to
repeated and prolonged periods of intense
stress, thus inducing symptoms of depression.
They then allowed the mice to reproduce, and
found that both the second and third generation
of offspring - showed the same symptoms of
trauma, despite never having experienced it
themselves.
Perhaps more interesting, the researchers
found that, like their parents', the sperm
of the second generation offspring also exhibited
abnormally high numbers of microRNAs.
However, the third generation did not - even
though maladaptive behaviors were clearly
present.
"It's possible," researchers say, "that the
alteration is transferred into another non-genetic
mark" before it hits the third generation
- but the overall results of the study, demonstrate
just how sensitive reproductive cells are
to early environmental conditions.
So, maybe something to consider if you plan
on having children.
Just a thought.
As always, if you have questions about this
study - there are links in the description
with more info.
Below that, is a comment box - for all your
sperm-related discussion.
Also, if you wanna know more fun sperm facts,
be sure to check out the latest episode of
Anyhoo.
Fascinating stuff.
Thanks for watching, and be sure to subscribe
here for more Dnews!